turning now to the pandemic the cdc says
the delta variant is now the dominant
covit 19 strain in the u.s
it accounts for more than 80 percent of
infections in parts of the midwest
overwhelming hospitals in states like
missouri where there's been a
sharp rise in hospitalizations in the
last month
nancy chen is in springfield missouri
and nancy how bad is the situation there
jamie good morning to you just as more
people are relaxing their behaviors a
hospital here
is seeing the most coveted patients that
has seen this entire pandemic
as doctors and those who have lost loved
ones are urging people
to stay vigilant debra carmichael lost
her daughter trisha jones to the delta
variant almost a month ago
it was so severe you you can't believe
how bad she looked physically and while
she was suffering of course internally
but this ferry is just brutal it takes
no prisoners
carmichael says jones was hesitant to
get the covet vaccine to begin with
but then she saw her mother get sick
after her first shot
that really freaked her out and then she
after that she was just
adamant that she wasn't going to even
mess with it by the time
she was kind of again thinking about
well maybe i should do this or something
she had already picked up koben as the
delta variant rages across the u.s
14 states including missouri still have
less than
50 percent of their populations
vaccinated new data from johns hopkins
warns
the rate of covett cases is almost three
times higher
in states with low vaccination rates
definitely we wouldn't want to be in
this position again
dr merrill jorez is a pulmonary critical
care physician
at missouri's mercy hospital springfield
where they've had to add a second
covet icu due to the rise in
hospitalizations
we have patients as young as newborns or
we have patients in between the ages of
30 plus the disease process is faster
than before
and they are getting sicker sooner than
before it feels like a lot of people
have let their guards down
it's very saddening to talk to a patient
and ask you know what will you do
different
and all of them in barely said i wish i
would have taken the vaccine
carmichael says that's what jones told
her after she got sick
she said mom you were right i should
have gotten the vaccine
and i should have worn my mask more i
think she kind of felt a little
overconfident that even if she got it
she would be okay
and dr horace tells us there is concern
that case members will keep going up
here now that we've just come out of a
major
holiday weekend tony not out of the
woods yet nancy thank you very much